let me
are we going i'm assuming this is being
videoed
let me know when we get going
this all feels very different it feels
like summer and we're in the wrong room
yeah we all graduated a month ago
yeah yeah it's like you forgot to pass
in your last paper and you have to come
back and do it
this is why people this is why
representative cody sort of never did
interim study so
let this be lesson to all of us for any
committee work in the future are we live
we are set all right good morning
everybody my name is barbara griffin it
is we are starting late this is the
house election law committee it is june
16th we are addressing interim study
bills and before we begin with this
state business i'm going to ask that
everybody join me in a pledge of
allegiance here today
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
can you give me the substitute
all right thank you everybody um as i
said this is uh has been noticed it's a
work study on the bills that we uh voted
interim study we're going to take a sh
we're going to discuss all of them then
we're going to take a short break and
then we'll come back and take a vote on
all of them um
the attendance today
we are fortunate to have some
substitutes here today and i just want
to acknowledge them representative don
johnson is here uh representative
maureen mooney has agreed to come back
to our committee again thank you thank
you i take that as a good sign uh
representative schultz is here good
morning and also representative nutting
wong is here thank you
um so thank you all of you for
substituting um and do not forget if you
have not done so to sign in for the
attendance roster
um the first uh we are doing interim
study bills and before we uh begin that
i want to just go through
what happens with interim study bills
for many uh for anybody who was here in
their first or second session this is
really the first time dealing with an
interim study bill because last session
of course ended early and there was no
interim study of any bills
so if you want to sort of find out what
happened you actually have to go back
to the prior session
that is two sessions ago so
the deadline for work on interim study
bills is actually after the summer in
the fall
if this feels like you're being dragged
back to school after graduation can you
imagine coming back here in september or
october to deal with these so we we're
trying to get this done in june
but the report deadline is technically
in the fall if you look at your calendar
you're going to see that date is in the
fall
and the calendar one of the last last
calendars of this session will come out
and i expect it will be at the beginning
of november and it will have the reports
from the interim study bills
but as you know as a body we will only
meet again for veto day
probably sometime in september
so these actually will not be voted on
um these simply go as a recommendation
to either file something in the future
or not we cannot vote on things
in regards to binding other sessions and
other sessions are not required to do
anything that we do if you want to look
at interim study reports you would go to
the 9
november 2018
house calendar
and that will be all of the the interim
study reports that were filed for the
bills of that session
and you will see that it is either the
bills are either recommended or not
recommended
and
there is no possibility to amend a bill
at this point
we are literally considering the bill
as it is that is the those are the only
two motions that can be made
so um
so some people
so there is a reason why interim study
is sort of referred to as the end of a
bill
because it is really difficult for the
committee if not impossible to do
anything substantively and obviously
legislators are
free to file legislation next session
regardless of what the recommendation of
any committee is on interim study bills
and you're not the only people have been
dragged back for this as you know we
were kicked out of our regular room
because someone else had already been
assigned it
all right so with that i asked uh
christina to go through some research so
we could figure out what if anything
else had happened so the first bill we
have today and i note that one of the
sponsors of 327 is with us today
is in regards to requiring that voter
show id when personally delivering
absentee ballots
this was introduced when we had it by uh
catherine prudhomme o'brien
representative who was prime sponsor of
the bill
we heard from
i think then deputy scanlan now he might
have been secretary at that point
in regards to the bill itself and there
were a number of questions in regards to
how to proceed
so
christina has done a memo
on that
and i'm going to open it up to
discussion now because i don't want to
leave this whole thing here
um and
if
representative hamlet
no i have a copy of an amendment
but
nobody else seemed to have that copy did
we just not
decide on the amendment
by rep
filed by representative marsh and
representative quailey
representative quailey's here yeah
do you recall your amendment i i don't
have it in my book on 327 when i pulled
stuff together for tonight
well i brought some material relevant to
that bill might be in here uh i have a
question though
we're
recommending and not recommending the
bill as introduced
because the amendment i think was
adopted by the committee but not by the
house
but was what was the amendment adopted
by the committee i don't remember i
don't know i'm going to have to i don't
have that it was adopted by the
committee okay that i might be
misremembering that and i'm i'm seeing
that
my legislative support here is but but
in any case since the bill was not
amended by the house then are we
recommending or not recommending the
bill as introduced we are okay thank you
um
so for so let me read a report from a
bill from a previous session it is not
an election law bill
um it was an environmental and
agricultural bill and it was not
recommended for future legislation
the full committee met with interested
parties regarding the issue this was
crop theft members of this committee
will be introducing new legislation in
the new biennium based on our findings
another one not recommended
the bill was retained and
subsequently referred
because
the committee felt that things needed to
be done
um ultimately the participants decided
that no more comprehensive bills should
be brought forward if those things
should not be addressed
and that this bill in its particular
form should not go forward
let me find one that's recommended
this one is a multiple employer public
retirement plan
the committee felt that the
that employers would benefit from
multiple plans this legislation as
written
will not work
things are changing at the federal level
and the committee strongly believes the
study committee should be formed to look
at those changes in regulation and how
other legislation has been working
before we fully implement this um
i'm sorry that was a not recommend
actually i printed out a sheet where it
looks like everything is not recommended
i don't know whether that's a sign for
me or not
oh no here here is um
one that's recommended the committee
recommends that legislation be
introduced to allow
retirement system to review positions
and not require an additional
legislative approval
so
it recommended
the concept but felt that there were
still problems so this is really what
pretty wide open as to what we do
so
representative clearly what had your
amendment sought to do to this bill
it attempted to refine the
signature matching requirement in part
added that
provision
attempted to fine-tune the signature
matching requirement i would say is a
good summary of what the amendment tried
to do
the issue with signature matching right
now as i think we mostly understand is
that it was uh
made invalid by a court decision
uh
i think that was
i forget the date of the court have it
here but anyways made it it was
uh
i guess i guess in regular english you
could say it was put on hold because of
some procedural problems
the court saw with
how it's conducted
the court decision is i understood the
decision and i did review it
as a layman not a lawyer but
it appeared to me that the court
decision
uh
ruled out signature matching based on
procedural difficulties for example lack
of training of moderators
uh to actually analyze handwriting
it didn't rule it out as a matter of
principle and in fact signature matching
is used in absentee ballots
when i read this last in 31 different
states including states like california
and nevada and so on
so the amendment by representative marsh
and i intended to
to fine-tune the procedure in the hopes
of
overcoming some of the
objections in the ruling
my recollection is accurate this is from
over a year ago but i believe we decided
it should go to interims we believed
ultimately as a committee should go to
interim study
because we really need to take a an
overall look at the signature matching
not just try to fix a piece of it here
and there
so
it deserves further consideration but
the bill is introduced
would have uh
the signature reviewed by the clerk and
make a marking that it had been no
excuse me the bill is originally
produced would have the
absentee voter prevent id present id to
the clerk
and then the clerk would make a notation
that would
say the
absentee ballot when received didn't
need to be signature matched
well that's kind of beside the point
right now because we don't have a
working signature matching system
thank you representative representative
bergeron i have some notes here about
your comments on some
needed work on the bill
yeah
one of the things i recall on
representative quayley's amendment too
was
a recommendation that we simplify the
marking of the envelope
and it would just say vv for voter
verified instead of a i p i d s appeared
in person id shown
uh which makes a lot of sense i'm all
for streamlining and making things more
efficient
one of the major objections though i had
to the bill
at the time was that
the clerk is being directed to mark the
absentee ballot affidavit
and under existing law the clerk is not
authorized to remove the affidavit
envelope from the outer envelope so
we're setting up a conflicting situation
here where one statute says the clerk
shall not remove the affidavit envelope
and another one is saying yeah go ahead
and take it away so that you can you can
mark up the affidavit envelope so that
issue needed to be resolved
and although i didn't bring it up at the
time
this uh and i can't find in state law so
it might be in the election procedures
manual
currently when uh designated agents are
delivering
absentee ballots let's say for example
from a nursing home
they have to show id and fill out a form
and present a letter that authorizes
them to do so
if we're going to start a process of
voter verification at the time envelopes
are being dropped off it would be nice
to have a process in place that applies
across the board to everybody
so that maybe we can get rid of these
forms
that are being filled out by family
members and by nursing home
representatives and just have a similar
voter verified process going through so
there's one
voter verification process being used
for all
instances of ballot delivery not have
one for one group another process for a
second group and so on
so those are some of the issues that
you know we we had discussed
any other committee members
represented with the committee's
permission there is a representative
here who was one of the sponsors of the
bill did you want to add anything to the
discussion on the come up and add
anything
all right the research that uh
attorney dyer got us indicated that
there was another bill going around with
this and i believe that was also part of
our discussion on it
um and it died in committee of
conference
so there were a couple of bills to deal
with this verification
but it doesn't look like anything passed
is there any further discussion on 327
all right
if there's not i'm going to move on
to the next bill like i said we'll go
through a discussion on all of these
take a short break and then we'll come
back
the next bill we have is 480
480 is relative to verification of
ballots cast in an election
we had a public hearing on this
in march
and
you have in the research from
christina dyer
that
there was a similar bill and the
information on this is contained in the
research memo that she sent out to us
so i'll give people a minute to look at
the research memo
i will say i was a little surprised when
i looked at the research memo how long
this issue has been floating around
just for members of the public who might
be watching we got a research memo one
day that was on public acc public access
to ballots
um where legislation also crossed over
into verification of ballots
and it turned out that this issue has
been
uh going on for
the last 10 years in regards to bills
that have been filed in regards to
verification of counts
and as to access it's been going on even
longer access to ballots cast an
election i think was back in
the testimony we heard on this went on
for some time as i recall
the testimony in the first instance was
introduction by jess edwards the
representative from auburn who was prime
sponsor of the bill
he acknowledged that this bill
had been submitted a number of times
before and while christina did not look
into the details of it i suspect it was
very similar to that first passed or
submitted in 2007
there was testimony in favor of it
the secretary of state's office was in
opposition
to
it in regards to
ballots having never been seen
and that there had been previously been
a court case in regards to this issue
and that the recount deals with the
issue of counting
and that there's concern over privacy of
the voter by
allowing
ballots public
anybody
representative bergeron thank you thank
you madam chair
um
there were a few issues that local
officials raised about this um
first of all the 28 a consideration
on page two for example it says the
towns and cities may request
reimbursement
of additional expenses from the
secretary of state
uh from the election fund established
under rsa 5 colon 6d
it doesn't say that the secretary of
state shall reimburse the cities and
towns for any expenses they occur and
they can be formidable
i know in nashua for example if we were
to have a city-wide recount it's going
to take all day
and that assumes enough people have been
recruited to work
uh on the on the recount so i assume
that it will require
a lot of uh
residents citizens whomever
that wishes to
do this looking or or counting of
ballots uh a day or or perhaps longer
there are no restrictions in the bill
that say how much time they need to get
this done for example if they only have
four people that show up to start
reviewing the ballots and they want to
review the city's entire ballots cast
boxes
it could take days
and city and town clerks have very
limited staff they don't necessarily get
a build up
at election time some some cities and
towns do build up staff so they have
their regular operations to take care of
this would require staff be pulled to to
remove the boxes from storage and then
be present when all these materials are
being counted
so that's going to increase staff
obligations and costs on the cities and
towns
there's also no limitation on who can
ask for the recounts it can be any
registered new hampshire voters so
presumably
a resident of nashua could go to
manchester and say we want to look at
all your ballots
that so that's a concern
there's no restrictions on how often
this can be done
presumably you might have 10 or 12
individuals that want to do this 10 or
12 different times because they each
have their own agenda they might be
looking for different
uh
issues when they're reviewing the ballot
so it's just too open-ended it's too
expensive and
there needs to be more controls in place
for
this bill to be seriously considered
anybody else
i think the ballot review issue is
something that's happened
obviously we see from the memo
over time we heard a lot about it in
this committee in public hearings
i think there are a lot of competing
interests to balance that so far
just
opening up ballots for inspection would
seem to be problematic we'll see where
the audit goes and that's our next bill
any other discussion on
hb 480.
all right moving on to hb 524
this was the
first year session
uh bill that we heard in regards to
audit it directed the secretary of
state's office to conduct hand recounts
at five randomly select selected
locations that use electronic counting
devices within 21 days after the general
election is held
this prime sponsor of the bill
representative lang is with us today
um and i will ask him to if he wants to
speak on this after we have a little
discussion
um it should be noted that hb 14 67
passed
in regards to a partial audit
which will occur
this fall
members comments
representative lang
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee
so
this bill was about
voter confidence in government
and so i asked that
you
recommend for future legislation i
understand there is some mechanical
issues in the bill that we need to
address and i will address if i refiled
and come back next year
but i think again the concept of the
bill is is sound
that like just like any public uh
company auditing of financials are
important
to prove um
you know have positive outlook on a
company when you're looking to invest or
looking to do something so again i think
that an audit or a verification count
like this is is needed i think the bill
on his face is a good concept um does
have mechanical issues which i'm happy
to work out next year should i return to
this fine body so thank you
thank you representative
did anybody have any questions for him
representative muirhead
thank you madam chair
uh
representative do you think that the
that hp 1467 which is passed by both
chambers addresses some of the concerns
that are meant to be addressed by hp 524
again i i i'm not
positive about that if you want to give
me a summary of what that bill was and i
can tell you whether i i agree with you
or not
uh
um was the product of a committee of
conference so that tells you something
uh and what it addresses is an audit in
the
primary and general election of 2022
only with a report to be published
that's that's a gross overview
anybody and representative bergeron
agrees
so again i i think that helps um i i
think an ongoing
at the state general election i'm not so
worried about the primaries but the
state general elections um an ongoing
um audit that's in statute will
slowly increase voter confidence in that
fact that the they think that their
ballot counted um just having a one-time
hit it's one of the reasons why again in
this bill i was interested i found out
that
the last time we've done a recount of a
statewide election was in the 70s i
believe
that's been 50 years since a statewide
race has been was that the senate race i
don't recall which race i remember was
in the 70s it was the senate yeah and so
representative mcdonald how many votes
uh well it shifted back and forth
initially it was like
ultimately two votes
so so again the idea being that
voter confidence is going to change
overnight that's going to take a long
term
process to to re to instill greater
voter confidence in in the election
process
especially given the
what's happened over the last few years
the elections so
again i think a one-time audit's great
but i think an audit of uh two percent
of every ballot and every race on every
on those that two percent is important
to instill voter confidence
thank you
further questions for representative
lang
representative hayward
thank you madam chair and thanks for
taking the question
the both of these bills including that
are truly
recount bills not audit bills i know
column audits but an audit would be a
much broader
look at
the processes and the procedures
okay
the application of
rules
some training assessment
it goes well beyond just the recount
and neither of those bills
fill that
void
i i would agree with you again i called
it a verification count because it does
two things right besides verifying what
the actual ballot counts were it
verifies that towns are doing it right
i'm a moderator um and and i welcome and
his secretary of state wants to come in
and
do a verification to make sure my
numbers are right and everything's
working you know the numbers i reported
were the actual numbers of the ballots
um i i think that's important because it
again
the random idea of this bill was the
fact that every town could potentially
be subjected to a verification count to
make sure that the processes they were
following are right that the ballot the
numbers they put on the moderators
report they call it that you put on and
you give to the secretary of state that
that matches
what was actual every piece of paper
that you have you're supposed to account
for
so it does besides giving a voter
confidence it also will make sure that
the process is being followed properly
right because you're verifying what's
reported by the town is what's
um is in a hand count is accurate
okay
anything else from committee members for
representative lang
thank you and representative
mooney
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for coming i also want to
bring your attention to senate bill 366.
uh which came to finance which i sit on
uh having been on this committee for a
year and now finance comes in handy in a
conversation like this but senate bill
366 were the random audits in the fall
so how does that and we've been talking
a lot about house bill 1467
so just want to bring that to your
attention and see if you have any
comments with regards to that because it
looks like it's getting ready for a
gubernatorial signature senate bill 366.
again i i'm not familiar with that bill
so i'd have to go back and read it um
you know so again i'll look at that
again that may add that may adjust again
if if the committee makes the
recommendation of of um
recommend for future legislation i'll
look at that bill as well and see if and
fill any gaps right because we all know
that first passes a bill sometimes are
not perfect so maybe between
recommending this and looking at that
bill we can find a more perfect
solution and thank you to representative
coyly our resident engineer for
providing the bill upon mention
to representative lang
anyone else for representative lang
all right i'm not seeing anything thank
you now representative lang anybody else
from the committee on this
sure representative bergeron thank you
madam chair
um
i don't have any questions for
representative blang i'm sorry
no no no i knew he's he's he's just
sitting there reading okay
i'm sorry i didn't mean to
kiss you
um
i i agree with uh the sponsor of the
bill that the concept of post-election
audits is sound
um
and i was on the committee conference
report that supported uh house bill
1467.
i was a little disappointed in it i
don't think it went far enough but it's
a start
and i think we can learn from that start
um you know in terms of
actually the secretary of state
conducting
um an audit of election results
working with the uh city and town clerks
and moderators to make it occur
and finding out what kinds of equipment
will work and get a better understanding
of the cost
so hopefully after you know 1467 is
implemented we can grow with that
foundation
and do something more
the national conference of state
legislators has some excellent
information on post-election audits and
what i found surprising is that there
are actually eight different types of
post-election audits
and
it would be
a value i think that any legislation
sponsors
be able to tell this committee
why
one type of audit is better than another
for new hampshire and that kind of
research i think still needs to be done
and i would note that
new hampshire is one of only i think
seven states that don't have some kind
of post-election audit so i definitely
feel that there is a need to do so
there's one other thing i would like to
see in future legislation
and that would be
a requirement that the state also
audit votes cast and towns and wards
that hand count their ballots
because it would be very easy to audit
uh the accubilt machines or any other
machine that's approved in the future
find out there's a there's a half of one
percent discrepancy and and have people
scream see it's not working
but if you're also auditing hand-counted
ballots and find that there's a three or
five percent discrepancy well then
suddenly
the uh electronic
voting devices have more accuracy than
than hand counting and i can tell you
from my own experience that uh the the
biggest discrepancies were usually found
in recounts and vote involving
hand-counted ballots uh for those of you
that have done recounts you know that
you probably have two candidates running
you're sorting the ballots and stacks of
25. it's very easy to take a stack of 25
and put it in the wrong candidate's pile
and suddenly you have a swing of 50
votes
so um
having that baseline to compare
the differences in an audit for
hand-counted ballot towns with those
that use electronic
uh voting devices i think would have
some value in any kind of post-election
audit so again
i i certainly support the concept of
post-election audits uh i don't think
that this particular bill uh is is the
one to use to address it at this time
but i am certain this committee will
review other suggestions in the next
session
further comments or discussion
all right the next bill we have in front
of us this morning is 5 51 relative to
the statewide voter database
this bill would require that the voter
registration database be made publicly
available in electronic format
provided that the secretary of state
could allow for limited
exceptions
it was
fairly broad
it was an issue of costs there was an
issue from the secretary of state's
office in regards to the fact this dealt
with the harvard database which had felt
that some of the information on there
was confidential
discussion representative sweeney thank
you madam chair um i do appreciate uh
the comparison chart that was produced
by christina
um
i know i believe i was the sponsor of hb
1010 and 223
and i believe representative barry who's
not here worked a lot on 1496 i believe
i helped him in his amendment language
i think in the last two years we've done
a lot on
voter people's access to
the voter rolls
1496 if signed
people can go to their supervisor or
their town and get the electronic list
of their checklist
there's access to
the checklist for folks that want it
we've made municipal voter history as
part of the statewide voter registration
database
we've increased the access that the two
recognized political parties in the
state and any organized political
organization have to reach out to the
secretary of state's office and get the
voter data that they're inquiring about
so i do believe that we've made so many
significant changes over the last
two years on what we have access to and
what individuals have access to so i'm
not sure
if the
spirit or the intent of 551 which as you
said was broad and
you know
kind of
full sweeping i think a lot of the
concerns that people have we did address
through the other legislation that we
did pass so i'm not sure if when we're
talking later about what we want to
recommend i think
you know
i think we might have covered it in
terms of what people were looking for in
terms of expanding access to the
information
so that's just one area where i think we
really did
um in a regulated you know particular
way
uh get to the point of what the
original sponsors were trying to get
accomplished with 551
that's just my take representative
bergeron thank you madam chair
and and i agree with everything that
representative sweeney said
um i just for the record would like to
mention
or
define if i could what words like broad
and sweeping
mean since the chair and representative
sweeney
pension use those words
the
legislation says that the voter database
shall be made electronically available
to members of the public
and that's not the same thing as the
checklist the voter database includes a
lot of elements a lot of fields of
information which contain
personal identifying information if
something as simple as dates of birth
for example which does not appear on the
checklist
one could argue that in addition to the
data fields
the voter database might include the the
coding the queries you know some of the
other software
um aspects that drive election net not
just the information that's contained
within it
so um i agree with representative
sweeney i think some progress has been
made in in making the checklists more
available to the public
but this one is too broad in sweeping
because of the term used voter database
anybody else
representative moorhead was that a hand
that was that was glasses in the air and
a nod just nodding in in general
affirmation
all right
the other thing no one is really talking
about is that this would provide
um
electronic access to a state database
that we don't currently allow and it
sort of has this
um
this line that sort of we really almost
didn't even discuss in regards to the
information it was going to provide
adequate technological security measures
to deter unu unauthorized access to the
records contained in the voter database
um
i'm not really sure it would be
responsible for a committee to pass
anything with that and the fiscal note
um
i don't know what fiscal would what the
finance committee would do with this
fiscal note because the fiscal note only
addressed the loss of revenue
not the expense of implementing it
as if staff was just going to take on
this project and be able to work it into
its current day
and given the issues with security and
the concerns we've had about a portal
for election information i don't
i'm not quite sure that even if we all
agreed it was something that should
happen
i don't know how with this bill you
could even get there
representative clearly
yes we had quite a lot of discussion on
this bill in in committee
and i recall very clearly that the
sponsor of the bill
himself
indicated that
his real intent was to have the
checklist information available readily
to the public
and he hadn't
i think i think i'll leave it at that
his
his real interest was in the checklist
information not all the data in the
database
okay
uh which which means this bill has
written
uh
i don't think it's one that i would
consider recommending in its form and
i think if the sponsor brought forth
a variant of this where it's focused on
his real interest
that would be an interesting thing to
see
thank you
anybody else
all right
um the last bill i have that we have
remaining from the session
is the absentee ballot application form
this is sb 54.
um
it is in regards to including certain
identity information for absentee
ballots uh we also had hb 144
which the senate simply none concurred
on
this particular bill
added
driver's license or some sort of
identification number the last four
digits of a social security number
or some sort of other information
discussion
representative mcdonald
thank you madam chairman
i had been a co-sponsor on this bill
initially and
some excellent testimony was was brought
up during the um the public hearing and
subsequent discussions
there is a privacy concern regarding the
last four digits of an applicant's
social security number that's a
legitimate concern
and also there's a question about the
availability of some of the
verifications we're asking for so
um
you know i um well i was originally a
co-sponsor i have misgivings about this
bill also and
and um
obviously um
want to hear what everybody else thinks
but i i definitely this leads needs more
work
anybody else representative bergeron
thank you madam chair and uh
i agree with representative mcdonald and
we'll expand on it just a little bit
um
the last few lines of the bill say that
the town clerk is authorized to verify
driver's license and non-driver's
picture id information
with the department of safety and was
brought up in testimony uh as
representative mcdonnell indicated that
the clerks don't necessarily have the
right to access this information for
this purpose
it also came out during testimony that
not all city clerks handle vehicle
registration so they don't have
authorization to enter the database at
all
and i think we're all aware that
driver's license numbers are changing
and a lot of the driver's license
information that may be contained and
voters who registered maybe five years
or more
ago
would have a driver's license different
driver's license number different than
what they currently have on on their
license so this it'll be hard to verify
numbers that don't match up anymore
and finally
election net was established in 2006
and
all the registered voter local databases
were migrated to election net in that
time
and most of them did not include
driver's license information because
that requirement came about with the
national voter registration act
or java as some people refer to it
and
so there are a lot of records election
records existing that
just doesn't contain driver's license
information anyway
so that's that's all i would
bring up on senate bill 54.
does anybody have a real id how does the
driver's license number differ on the
real id anybody know
i have one but i don't know
madam chair that just made me think
i'm just wondering whether well i mean
just does it
is it do you know what did the number
you get does it's did it stay the same
no so it used to go by the name and date
of birth
and now it's just the break of a number
that's up with nhl right nhl yeah i used
to
refresh your name
i kind of resented it when they gave me
this because i got my license in 1982 in
manchester and i had the same number the
whole time even when i moved back to the
state that gave me my old number and
then when i got my real id they gave me
this i can't always remember it because
of my birthday you know
jumble of your birthday right right
and now i got this long thing it means
doesn't mean anything so this is the new
administrative state's
solution to
real id
and so just
does anybody know if this d and i think
i know the answer this question if dmv
updates your driver's license number in
accordance with your new driver's
license does that automatically update
on other
departments databases
let me guess the answer to that one
government are talking
yeah
all right so that's i i hadn't even
thought of that when we were talking
about driver's license numbers all this
term in a number of cases whether it be
four or five digits because there was
some discussion about going to five
digits because the issue with four
digits is just like your birth date it's
really not enough of a distinguisher
filled and i had to go because
and there was another
gentleman with the same
initial and the same date of birth
numbers that they used they tried to
give me his license i said do i look
like hamper
so
i think that's part of why we might have
seen some things talking about or her
discussion about using five digits for
the social security number
so
um couple of issues with that
any further discussion on sb 54.
all right any further discussion for
what i noticed as a work session
um for these bills
all right we're going to take a break
till 10 past 11 and then we're gonna
exact all these bills
madam chair representative moorhead what
room are the refreshments in
[Laughter]
i think the cafeteria is still open
across the way downstairs
all right
good morning still everybody this is the
new hampshire house election law
committee we are back in session
we spent time earlier this morning
talking about the five bills that are
noticed
to be
dealt with as the end of our
session work the first bill is hb 327
this is requiring that voters show
identification when personally
delivering
absentee ballots to town and city clerks
we talked about the pros and cons and
what this was attempting to do
is there
a motion on hb 327
representative hayward
madam chair i would move that we do not
recommend this to going forward
hb 327. is there a second representative
sorry madam chair i didn't hear the uh
comments
what's what was you want to repeat your
motion representative hayward
uh yes madam chair i uh move that we do
not recommend this going forward
is there a second i'll second that madam
chair representative bergeron seconds it
representative hayward did you want to
speak to your motion
um madam chair i believe we covered
the information uh adequately to this
point
anything further
are you all set to call the role
all right if there's no further
discussion i'm going to ask the clerk to
call the role
okay um representative mcdonald votes
yes
uh representative
who's in for captain
no catherine's
absent okay
representative sweeney is not here at
the moment um representative haywood yes
representative to ocean is right absent
um representative johnson
yes
uh representative quailey yes
um
representative mooney yes
representative bergeron yes
representative schultz
yes
representative ward yes
representative sandler
representative hamer yes
representative lane yes
representative nutting wong
yes
representative hamlet
representative murrahad
yes
representative griffin yes
okay
vote is 15 2-0
thank you the next bill that is uh for
our consideration this morning is hb 480
relative to the verification of ballots
cast in an election we had discussion on
this this morning uh and our discussion
was about the extensive discussion we've
had previously on this is there a motion
all right
i move madame chairman not
recommend is there a second
i'll second madam chair
thank you representative mcdonald did
you want to speak to your motion
well again we've discussed that at
length and um
we we've i think the consensus of the
committee is that
this legislation needs much more work
for it to be effective and uh certainly
not ready to go i recommend to go
forward at this time
any further
discussion all those in are going to ask
the clerk to call the role
representative berger are you second to
that i believe yes i did thank you
okay hb 480 representative mcdonald
votes yes
um
see
representative haywood yes
representative johnson yes
representative quailey
yes
representative mooney
representative bergeron yes
representative schultz
yes
representative ward yes
representative sandler
representative hamer yes
representative lane yes
representative netting wong
yes
representative hamlet
representative muirhead
yes
representative griffin
15-0 madam chairman
thank you hb 480
is not recommended for future
legislation the next bill we considered
here this morning and we'll now take a
vote on is hb 524
this was a bill requiring the secretary
of state to conduct random verification
counts of polling place results
is there a motion
representative quailly
thank you madam chairman i move that the
committee not recommend this bill
is there a second
second second representative bergeron
seconds it
um did you want to speak to your motion
representative clearly
uh yes very briefly i think the concept
of post-election audits has a great deal
of merit
uh but would be worthwhile to institute
a procedure like that in this state
however i think the best approach would
be to start with a fresh bill rather
than try to continue with this one
thank you
is there any further discussion
which is hp 524
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll
representative mcdonald votes yes
representative haywood yes
representative johnson
representative qualy
yes
representative mooney yes
representative bergeron yes
representative schultz
yes
representative ward yes
representative sandler
representative hamer yes
representative lane yes
representative nutting wong yes
representative hamlet
yes
representative murrahad
representative griffin
yes
15-0 madam chairman
the next bill for our consideration here
this morning
is hb 551.
this is relative to the statewide voter
database and access to it
is there emotion
since we're spreading the joy
i'll move it you can take the next one
so i move hb 551
uh
not recommend
is there a second oh second man
representative bergeron second set
in regards to 551 we had a pretty good
good discussion on this this morning
there were a number of issues in regards
to the database
and the bill itself in regards to the
fiscal note
and while we understand the desire to
have access there's other legislation
that's been adopted that provides more
access than we've had in the past and
we'll take steps as are deemed
appropriate is there any further
discussion on it
seeing none i'm going to ask the acting
clerk i apologize representative
mcdonald has
been doing a number of roles here today
so to call the roll thank you
thank you madam chairman
representative mcdonald votes yes
representative haywood yes
representative johnson yeah
representative quailey yes
representative mooney
yes
representative bergeron yes
representative schultz yes
representative ward yes
representative sandler
representative hamer yes
representative lane yes
representative netting wong yes
representative hamlet yes
representative muirhead
yes
representative griffin
15-0 madam chairman
the last bill to be considered by the
committee today and this session is sb
54 relative to the absentee ballot
application form
is there a motion
representative
thank you madam chair i move uh that we
do not recommend
forward
hp i'm sorry sb
54. is there a second oh second man
representative bergeron seconds
did you want to speak to your motion
uh madam chair the uh is unworkable in
its current form
thank you
any further discussion
brevity is the solar whip
and that can be written in the report
all right seeing no discussion i'm going
to ask the clerk to call the role
representative mcdonald votes yes
representative haywood
yes representative johnson yeah
representative quayley yes
representative mooney yes
representative bergeron yes
representative schultz
yes
representative ward yes
representative sandler
representative hamer yes
representative lane yes
representative netting one yes
representative hamlet yes
representative muirhead yes
representative griffin yes
15-0 madam chairman thank you
and that is the last vote
um
i want to thank everybody for coming in
this morning to actually finish up the
business in this sort of strange
territory and strange motions in regards
to bills that we can't do anything with
one way or another
one thing that has changed since the
last time we met as an election law
committee is that sign ups have happened
and i happen to know that representative
hayward did not sign up to run again
so i want to extend my thanks to
representative hayward that it's been a
pleasure to work with him um and i want
to thank him very much for being part of
this committee and doing this work for
his constituents it's been a pleasure to
have you here so thank you very much
is there anybody else who didn't sign up
again
representative sandler and myself are
not returning
i did not know that yes
well that is um i will say to both of
you i think that's a loss to the house
well thank you it's a huge loss to this
committee
um appreciate it and i thank everybody
for the support and respect that was
shown during the last four years i've
served in this committee and uh i wish
everyone a wonderful summer and great
success not because representative
griffin and i were too tough to work
with
not at all not at all
thank you representative bergeron and
representative sandler i know that you
worked very hard to be here and to do
the work here and
i really appreciate what i know you went
through to be here with us it it meant a
lot that you wanted to be part of this
and with that we are done
have a great summer everybody
you